Let us discuss the performance
of a benchmark algorithm.
The Random Forest
algorithm is known
for its attractive property of
detecting variable interactions
and excellent performance
as a learning algorithm.
For the decision, we're
selecting the Random Forest
algorithm as a
benchmark-- initially,
we randomly partitioned
the full data
set into two separate parts,
where the split was 50-50,
and the partitioning was done
evenly within each cost bin.
The first part,
the training set,
was used to develop the method.
The second part,
the test set, was
used to evaluate the
model's performance.
The table in this slide
reports the accuracy
of the Random Forest algorithm
on each of the three buckets.
Let us now introduce
the idea of clustering.
Patients in each bucket may
have different characteristics.
For this reason, we create
clusters for each cost bucket
and make predictions for each
cluster using the Random Forest
algorithm.
Clustering is mostly used in
the absence of a target variable
to search for relationships
among input variables
or to organize data
into meaningful groups.
In this study, although
the target variable
is well-defined as a heart
attack or not a heart attack,
there are many
different trajectories
that are associated
with the target.
There's not one set
pattern of health
or diagnostic combination that
leads a person to heart attack.
Instead, we'll
show that there are
many different dynamic health
patterns and time series
diagnostic relations
preceding a heart attack.
The clustering
methods were used were
spectral clustering
and k-means clustering.
We focus, in the lecture,
on the k-means clustering.
The broad description of
the algorithm is as follows.
We first specify the
number of clusters k.
Then we randomly assign each
data point to a cluster.
We then compute the
cluster centroids.
We re-assign each point to
the closest cluster centroid.
We then re-compute
the cluster centroids,
and we repeat steps 4 and 5
until no improvement is made.
Let us illustrate the
k-means algorithm in action.
We specify the desired
number of clusters k.
In this case, we use k=2.
We then randomly assign each
data point to a cluster.
In this case, we have
the three points in red,
and the two points in black.
We then compute the
cluster centroids,
indicated by the red
x and the grey x.
We re-assign each point to
the closest cluster centroid,
and now you observe that
this point changes from a red
to a grey.
We re-compute the
cluster centroids,
and we repeat the
previous steps, 4 and 5
until no improvement is made.
We observe that, in this case,
the k-means clustering is done,
and this is our
final clustering.
Let us discuss some
practical considerations.
The number of clusters
k can be selected
from previous knowledge or
by simply experimenting.
We can strategically select
initial partition of points
into clusters if we have
some knowledge of the data.
We can also run the
algorithm several times
with different random
starting points.
In the recitations,
we'll learn how
to run the k-means
algorithm in R.
So how do we
measure performance?
After we construct the
clusters in the training set,
we assign new observations
to clusters by proximity
to the centroid of each cluster.
We measure performance
by recording
the average performance
rate in each cluster.
Let us now discuss the
performance of the clustering
methods.
We perform clustering on each
bucket using k=10 clusters.
In the table we record
the average prediction
rate of each cost bucket.
We observe a very
visible improvement
when we use clustering-- from
49% to 64%, from 56% to 73%,
from 58% to 78%.